foreign
[Music]
here in this video we will tell you who
is going to be Vega's next Rider we will
tell you why this is so significant to
the storyline and the power struggle as
well as what will happen to vegar in the
end of the dance of the Dragons oh let's
say the show let's get to it
so yeah vegar is the only surviving
dragon from aegon's conquest and is
currently the biggest dragon in the show
as of now she is a female dragon with
pale yellow scales and a rubbery
leathery skin which signifies her old
age being more than 150 years in the
current timeline of the series she is a
massive dragon that is easily over 200
feet long or 60 meters a small figure
than our initial estimates of her being
around 250 to 300 feet long but
nevertheless the biggest and most robust
Dragon yet she has a very powerful fire
breath as well as a deadly bite force as
evident from her massive Jaws
so getting to the topic at hand who are
the first second and third writers of
vegar firstly let's discuss this well
the very first Targaryen this gigantic
Beast first bonded with was Queen
visenya the sister wife of aegon
Targaryen himself and when she died Vega
remained Unwritten for 29 years spending
much of that time on Dragonstone and
later taking residence in the dragon pit
in King's Landing then bail on the brave
another Targaryen then claimed the
yellow dragon and alongside karaxi's and
Verma Thor set out to burn the Danish
Fleet when they tried to invade the
stormlands in 101 AC when Balon died
vegar again became radulus until she met
Elena valerion who had Targaryen blood
from her mother Princess rainas Lena
then Bonnet with the dragon and became
the third Rider to claim Vega as seen in
the show
so what happened to Lena valerion well
in the books Lena died early in 120 AC
at the age of 17. it is said that Lena
attempted to reach Vega in her final
hour as to fly one last time but she did
not have the strength but in the show
Lena was already a grown woman with two
daughters and a third child on the way
it was seen that she wasn't able to
deliver the baby without herself dying
due to the crude form of cesarean
section that was performed in that age
so she instead pleaded Vega to burn her
alive to which the dragon did so but
reluctantly as she was her Rider and had
Bonnet with her for quite a long time
and flew on top of the Dragon for quite
a while
so now we come to the Crux of the topic
who will be Vega's next Rider so now
after Lena's death Vega for the third
time has become riderless again and was
a very old dragon now so shortly after
Lena's funeral in drift Mark a young
prince Ling Amon Targaryen who was the
only one out of the four young Targaryen
princes without a dragon of its own will
approach the mass of bees and form a
connection with the dragon which would
also be the last Rider This Magnificent
creature would have it is seen in the
episode 7 trailer that the Valerian
girls stating that someone is stealing
Vega which isn't really a crime as
dragons are free creatures that form
their own bonds and choose their Riders
free from outside control so here in
this next episode aemon will claim vegar
for himself and this is a game changer
this act of aemon claiming Vega as its
own dragon is a very important event as
it changes the power structure and
balance in the vine families of the
targaryens which would eventually lead
to all-out war but why is it so
game-changing well most of the
targaryens already have their own
dragons even the young princes the
bigger dragons like vegar karaxis Verma
Thor Silverwing just to name a few have
always been sort of neutral or on the
side of Princess renera Targaryen the
heir to the Iron Throne after her father
King viserys now another faction the
greens led by Queen Alison would for the
first time have a Fighting Chance as we
know Prince aegon was the only one on
their side that has a dragon sun fire
but this Dragon was still a small
fledgling male
so with the largest and most powerful
Dragon on their side the chessboard has
a new playable Queen but how will aemon
use Vega in the Show versus how he did
in the books while judging on how the
character of aemon is as of now in the
series it seems that he will be a
spiteful Prince with a jet to settle
with the Valerian princess as well as
making a name for himself as being the
writer of the most powerful Dragon
during that age we won't spoil much but
what we can tell you is that Vega will
be the cause of quite a few Dragon
deaths and hundreds or even thousands of
people burning to ashes in the upcoming
War
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash the
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam